super quick and he's so hard to finish
the block near the fringes is so long
Jimmy Butler taken a personal kid right
back in town seven to twenty routes of
the court 5:45 left first quarter Sixers
by dream Butler for two second scores
her bucket pick apart
up top look at them with the pass here
finding Jimmy Butler on this possession
running to the rim so touched by but
he's got the ability to do that when a
beat plays that for thirty five apiece
6:20 left first half here at the HS
that's Butler and that's good Jimmy
pepper and first half points and he's
given me either two point we could mix
up though Butler with the steal here he
comes within us giving chase didn't
matter
Jimmy Butler six in the NBA in steel
Mike Scott former Virginia Cavalier way
off on the attempted three Butler the
open man for an Eaton touchstone just
the second turnover the game Pam got it
right back Jimmy Butler colliding with
Scott counts the Heat have been coming
up with those getting down and dirty
there is Pam able to find that extra
possession 50/50 ball find Jimmy who
takes the hit it gets it up that's the
key to be able to get a two-shot foul
you've got to release the ball on
contact and Jimmy gives it a chance get
it up over the rim somehow Jimmy right
now six for six Miami holding the Sixers
under 42% shooting and forcing a
turnover
[Applause]
[Music]
cuz JoEllen beat on the left side of
your picture got pulled away from the
rim by Myers was scoreless in the first
half able to get just one field goal
attempt Jimmy Butler from the elbow
backs it
points for mine when Beavis 26
double-double this year's shake number
finished
he's a steamroller tonight putting
Sixers on their heels right now
excellent triple handoff type action by
bam Jimmy ran hard down the middle of
the floor set it up that Simmons giving
it room he'll shoot the three Gary
17 games he'd only triple twice slaying
him drive Ben Simmons again knocked down
in a stance he's backed off walks into
that gets his feet set much better
Duncan Michigan 15 footer
he then kept the lot by Derrick Jones
junior Butler tries again for three
putting the heat on his back with 34
points and two straight threes in this
quarter he's been his last five shots
love him tonight Butler with 34 points
watch for the line here is poplar it's
good to all-stars talk about right now
Jimmy 38 and 3/4 take us through that
feeling tonight I felt great
I felt like Lu got there you know that
that's what he'd be doing and it's
really impressive more than anything I'm
super happy that we got the dough